- And who knew you could
make beans desserts?
Why have I not been
making beans into dessert?
I love the moon and I love cake.
- I like astronauts.
- How could this go wrong?
- It sounds just colorful
and magical and happy.
- If this tastes like
half the effort that looks
like that went into
making it, it's gonna be
amazing.
- So beautiful, look at it.
- It's a egg? Ew.
- I got the one with the big egg.
- It's an egg?
- Is it gonna be good?
- Not bad.
- Whoah, I actually really like it.
- I didn't know lotuses
could be better, they're
already so beautiful.
- If it gets too buttery
around the tongue, this tea
really washes it down quite nicely.
- Okay, I'm skeptical of the red bean.
- Well, I've had mochi
with red bean in it,
it's pretty good.
- Also delicious.
- Mm-hm.
- It's like super earthy.
- Less crumble to deal
with because there's no
like center of cake.
- Pretty damn good sugar bean.
- Ooh
- Date sounds really good.
- Smells like meat.
- Ooh, kinda bittery.
- It's like a super thick fig newton.
- Yeah.
- Tastes like really old barbecue sauce.
- Still good, my least favorite.
- It was some baller (mumbles)
- It was beautiful, like I
felt bad cutting into them.
- A snack fit for a queen.
- I'm a go with the red bean.
- The lotus one was the best one for sure.
- I love the tea with
it, I feel really cozy.
- I just feel like so calm.
- I would love to bring this to my family.
- Can we just start doing this?
Can we just get together
- We should
- and have tea and cakes together?
- a little tea time?
- I love this.
If the queen of England visited East Asia,
this is the ceremony you'd
want to bring her to.
- Moon cake and tea.
- Moon cake and tea, she'd
be like right in her element.